aujourd'hui les entrepreneurs africains
n'ont pas besoin d'être financières
n'ont pas besoin quand les assists ils
ont besoin de co construire des choses
pragmatique qui crée une relation
win-win entre la france et les
entrepreneurs africains
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant le sommet on va travailler pendant
48 heures sur des ateliers de design
thinking pour pouvoir en fait imaginer
et créer une communauté d'entrepreneurs
africains et français qui peuvent
collaborer d'une nouvelle génération qui
veut collaborer pour pouvoir trouver des
marchés dans les deux sens qu'ils
peuvent trouver des talents mais aussi
qu'ils peuvent s'entraider sur des
problématiques du quotidien donc à
l'issue de ces deux jours de design
thing on a fait une restitution ce matin
justement pendant le sommet france
afrique dans lequel on a présenté les
travaux à plus de 400 entrepreneurs
africains qui ont adhéré à cette
communauté et qui va voir le jour
certainement au début des années compris
qu'il faut construire il faut former une
nouvelle dynamique à nous voir un
écosystème entrepreneurial dynamique
entre le sud et le nord tenait en train
de voir en fait quelque part un dialogue
inverser une co-construction si ça qui
est important l'idée c'est de voir
qu'est-ce que je commençais résultats
abandonnait et comment la population nos
startups en afrique ou aux bénéfices et
des abcès la question aujourd'hui c'est
comment il va de gouverner cette perte
sont certes en fait il y a un historique
qui l'a qui existent mais si je suis là
c'est parce que j'y crois que j'ai envie
de voir que ça arrive je pense que les
entrepreneurs africains et français
peuvent mieux travailler ensemble et et
c'est quelque chose qui peut arriver à
partir du moment où on commence à y
croire cette plate forme aujourd'hui
doit savoir que l'avenir du monde c'est
à l'afrique et si l'afrique et sousse le
monde qui sourd et après d'innovation
leur à ce moment à l'afrique ici parce
que ça l'a fait qui a mis le problème et
les solutions m2m solution doit venir de
l'afrique et la jeunesse africaine entre
le travailler pour ça et nous sommes en
train de travailler pour apporter les
solutions on a vu covin latine a mis en
branle toutes les civilisations
aujourd'hui on avait toute la difficulté
est aujourd'hui l'afrique porte une
solution et l'innovation et
l'entrepreneuriat est là mais
l'écosystème aujourd'hui de façon
globale afin d'apporter une solution
[Musique]